[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm adrian finnegan this is
counting the cost on al jazeera you'll
look at the world of business and
economics this week the us and uk ban
russian oil and the european union
announced its plans to drastically
shrink its reliance on gas from russia
will high prices undermine global energy
security
higher fuel costs and longer routes to
bypass russian airspace house sanctions
against moscow are battering the global
aviation industry with ticket prices and
freight rates poised to go up
and sri lanka reels from food shortages
and power cuts as it struggles to repay
its foreign debt and pay for imports is
the country on the verge of defaulting
on its debt
[Music]
it is the world's largest exporter of
natural gas and the second largest oil
exporter energy is russia's biggest
source of income but now u.s president
joe biden has imposed a ban on russian
oil and gas in response to the invasion
of ukraine the uk says that it will
phase out russian oil by the end of the
year while the european union is aiming
to cut gas imports by two-thirds this
year now the move will worsen inflation
and push up fuel prices and washington
is scrambling to find alternative
suppliers al jazeera's priyanka gupta
reports
a major escalation of u.s economic
sanctions against russia for its
invasion of ukraine
u.s president joe biden is going after
president vladimir putin's most
lucrative industry
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine biden acknowledged the
latest sanctions could push up u.s gas
prices
consumers are already paying on average
more than four dollars a gallon up from
two dollars and seventy seven cents just
a year ago due to high inflation as the
economy recovers from the pandemic
but it's europe that will feel the
effect of moving away from russian
energy more acutely than the us
the european union imports 27
of its oil and 40 of its gas from russia
the block plans to cut its dependency on
russian gas by two-thirds this year
it's hard
but it's possible if we're willing to go
further and faster than we've done
before
but experts say this decision will mean
difficult compromises there'll have to
be additional use of nuclear which is
supposed to be phased out in certain
countries they'll have to be more coal
use which won't help climate goals
the u.s is seeking to persuade opec
members to ramp up output among them
only saudi arabia the united arab
emirates and kuwait have spare capacity
and washington is also turning to
countries it has shunned and imposed
sanctions on it's making overtures to
venezuela and attempting to seal a
nuclear deal with iran that could bring
more oil into the market
priyanka gupta for counting the cost
joining us now from london toby
whittington lead economist at oxford
economics toby great to have you with us
on counting the cost is this ban on uh
russian imports of oil in the into the
u.s largely symbolic
the u.s uses something like eight
percent of of russian oil is that
correct
yeah that's that's right i mean i think
you're absolutely right it is a largely
symbolic move um
you know obviously
u.s demand or u.s usage of
russian oil is fairly limited um and i
think substituting out to to alternative
suppliers i think probably within the
north american market would be possible
uh there may be some sort of frictional
costs in the in the process of doing
that uh but those those would be sort of
temporary and quite moderate and so we
wouldn't expect too much of a a price
shock from this movement in terms of oil
is there anyone that who could plug the
gap the us
appears to be
making attempts to repair relations with
venezuela which of course has huge oil
stocks but its infrastructure isn't
isn't in any fit shape at the moment and
of course the iran nuclear deal
talks
could come to some sort of fruition and
sanctions might be lifted on iran could
venezuela and iran perhaps help offset
the shock
i think those are both two uh key key
markets and certainly given the the
situation we're in there is an impetus
now to try to bring those two countries
back into the to the global oil market
uh discussions are ongoing uh as you say
i think venezuela's oil infrastructure
is in a slightly uh poorer state than
what it is in iran uh i think iea
estimates put them at around about 700
000 uh barrels a day that they could
start exporting uh iran is a bit higher
roughly around about 1.3 million barrels
a day that they could put out by the end
of the year and uh with potential to
upgrade even further um so so those are
important markets but i think the key
sort of producers are as ever the the
major opec producers saudi arabia and
the uae now as well okay and you talk
about europe
looking to to wean itself off of russian
gas we're not talking about oil here
and perhaps its plans being a little
overly optimistic at the moment who
would fill the gap there would it be
countries like qatar australia i mean
you're looking at shipping gas from the
other side of the world to europe i mean
can that be done
you know the three major sort of lng
exporters of the us qatar and australia
i think australia is pretty out of the
picture they they overwhelmingly supply
the australian market so the asian
market and of course getting gas from
from uh shipping gas from australia to
europe is a huge endeavor i think it
would come primarily from the u.s and
qatar
it's not entirely clear that
enough export capacity exists at the
moment so as part of the eu plan if they
want to withdraw reduced dependence on
russian gas by two thirds within 2022 so
that's nine months essentially to to do
it um and half of that two-third saving
is going to come from extra lng imports
uh which which
roughly equates to around about a 60 to
70 increase in in in eu imports of lng
uh i think that's highly optimistic uh
given given current export capacities
and also uh eu import capacities of lng
um i think if they could reduce
dependence by maybe a third that would
be very good i think two-thirds is is
probably pushing it too far really and
is this i mean this is all about
sanctioning russia it's it's it's a
financial penalty for russia it's it's
aimed at causing economic harm to russia
ultimately though is is russia still
going to be able to sell its oil and gas
will there be buyers out there will it
be able to sell still sell at market
price is it really going to hurt russia
well i think undoubtedly in the long run
i think you know if russia loses access
to western markets it's lost access to
the us um if it also loses access to
europe as europe seems to be implying uh
you know that will will have um impact
on on russian uh on demand for russian
oil which should uh reduce the price
that they can pay i mean they're going
to be able to sell to to other countries
uh china uh in the asian countries and
so on um but but that sort of reduced
number of buyers will necessarily i
think uh reduce the the amount of price
they can pay i think that's true also
gas um as europe seeks to wean itself
off euro of russian gas um
russia is in the process of transiting
to china uh building new pipeline
infrastructure to to supply uh gas from
from the yamaha field down into down
into china but that's a massive
infrastructure effort that will take
some time to come online uh and also
china will be in quite a strong
bargaining position of course um you
know with russia not having many other
customers china will will be able to to
leverage that position to negotiate
themselves a bit of deal so
yeah in some i think it rushes the price
that they can
achieve for their energy exports will
will undoubtedly go down
toby it's been great to talk to you on
counting the cost many thanks indeed for
being with us thank you
the surge in oil prices has pushed the
cost of global jet fuel to a 14-year
high airlines and travelers are facing
steep fare increases just as air travel
was beginning to recover after covert
19. well adding to the burden of high
prices are the circuitous flight paths
needed to avoid russian airspace right
now the biggest impact is on flights
between europe and asian destinations
like japan south korea and china longer
flight times lead to higher staff costs
limited cargo carrying ability and they
raise maintenance costs and russian
airlines have also been hit by the
airspace bands they won't be able to
access parts and services that they'd
sourced from abroad
to discuss all of this joining us from
london peter morris chief economist at
the aviation consultancy ascend by
syrian peter good to have you with us on
counting the cost just as airlines were
beginning to spot a patch of clear skies
after the horrible time they've been
through with the pandemic here we have
more turbulence caused by higher oil
prices i mean just how bad an impact is
this going to have on an already
suffering aviation sector
well it's yet another negative i mean if
if you look at this proportion of global
aviation that is linked directly to
russia it's of the order of six percent
or so which you can say
you know could be managed without but on
the other hand what you're talking about
is yet another negative factor and we
haven't even got to the level of the
increase in fuel prices that appears to
have been linked to this whole uh
invasion so
what will higher oil prices higher fuel
prices mean for the likes of you and i
the people who use the airlines is that
going to lead to higher ticket prices
for us
it's inevitably going to lead to higher
ticket prices but there will be a kind
of differential in the effect so when
you're traveling for example within
europe the proportion of the ticket
that's fuel is lower whereas when you're
traveling to australia for example it's
a much higher proportion so it will mean
that short haul
is impacted less than long-haul travel
that's more than three hours not only is
is fuel going to cost more but airlines
are going to have to use more of it to
fly around russian airspace a vast part
of the globe that they now have to avoid
i think there's two factors here first
of all yes it will increase flight times
by between one and four hours between
europe and asia but on the other hand if
you look at the level of closure on
international services that's taking
place
in japan and china at the moment
that actually that traffic is very badly
hit anyway but again this is yet another
negative that's added in and one thing
it does mean is that the the airlines
that have newer fleets that are more
fuel efficient saving perhaps 20 of fuel
on journeys will actually have a
competitive benefit compared with others
they'll still be suffering in paying the
higher costs but
they will have something of a
competitive advantage
what does the the ban on uh on russian
aircraft flying into european uh
airspace for example what does that mean
for russia's aviation sector
well it's been very badly hit as as
symbolized by the uh
aeroflot withdrawing services
internationally from the 8th of march so
as a consequence they're not flying for
fear that the planes could be impended
and there's something like 500 aircraft
according to our databases that are
leased into russian entities from
international leasing companies and
those effectively the leases have to be
terminated by the 28th of march
so that means that any aircraft that's
sent flying outside can be impounded and
also under
international law the airlines are
supposed to be handing those aircraft
back
if they don't hand them back because
they simply can't at the moment due to
circumstances what does that mean for
the international leasing companies
they're going to lose money of course
because these these aircraft are sitting
on the ground in russia and they they
can't get to them
it is a major challenge one way or
another and
the thing is
we can only look at the unfolding um
impact of the sanctions and so on but it
is clearly one of the
major impacts that will be seen in
russia among russian air travelers
realizing you can't fly as easily or as
cheaply as you did before
and it will mean that for example the
middle eastern airlines who do fly to
russia will actually have a significant
captive market
we lost a lot of airlines uh due to the
pandemic it just wasn't survivable for
for many of the smaller airlines or
those running on on very tight
operational budgets um
with this continuing agony now with the
the the airspace restrictions around
russia with the increasing fuel prices
do you think that that we're likely to
see other airlines going under
it's going to increase the pressures
ultimately it's really what the impact
on individual countries gdp is because
it's its gdp and the ability of people
to buy tickets effectively that drives
the airline business forward and one of
the concerns is the impact in terms of
gdp growth will actually reduce
aviation growth as well but you know
none of these things are positive is the
basic point all looking at a little
bleak at the moment to say the least
peter but anyway thank you i really
appreciate you outlining all of that for
us uh peter morris there in london thank
you
now food shortages power cuts and long
lines for expensive fuel sri lanka is
facing its worst economic crisis since
independence in 1948. international
rating agencies are warning that it's on
the verge of defaulting on its debts but
the government has refused to seek an
imf bailout and insist that it can
handle the crisis on its own al
jazeera's menel fernandez reports from
colombo
spending hours in queues has become the
norm across sri lanka starting with food
rice sugar and milk powder now it's
cooking gas and diesel that are in short
supply
i haven't eaten from the morning and i
can't even go drink some water i would
lose my place otherwise
after spending so many hours in queues
we can only run about two and a half
days we can't keep doing this so we
appeal for this problem to be solved
the shortages are a result of the
government not having enough dollars to
pay for imports this is because its
foreign earnings and reserves have been
rapidly declining since 2019.
huge debt repayments have eaten into a
big chunk of available resources
the crisis has affected all sectors
including public transport
operators say they are struggling to
survive from day to day
on the one hand there's no electricity
they cut power for seven and a half
hours the diesel stocks that come half
is given for power generation it's only
half the stock that's used for
everything else
after months of coping people are
protesting here in chile north of
colombo fishermen complain they don't
have fuel for their boats
my husband can't go to sea there's no
diesel i hope those responsible are
struck by lightning
in colombo a silent protest
enough is enough says one banner
stop ruining my country reads another
months of skyrocketing prices and
shortages of food medicine cooking gas
and fuel have made sri lankans
frustrated and angry
to make matters worse
they've suffered through the worst power
cuts to be imposed in more than 25 years
seven and a half hour interruptions a
day are causing chaos among all segments
of the population
sri lanka's public utilities regulator
says it has been pushing to solve the
power crisis this has become a national
issue so
necessary uh
the attention has not been paid by the
political hierarchy then and now and the
other authorities so we have been
fighting you know
with almost everyone to sort out this
issue increasing prices and shortages
are not unique to sri lanka but people
here say their leaders have aggravated
the situation through years of
corruption and mismanagement
foreign currency reserves have plunged
below 1 billion
now the rising cost of oil imports is
shrinking that even further leaving it
vulnerable to a debt default the tourism
sector a major foreign exchange earner
was battered by the easter attacks of
2019 and of course the coronavirus
pandemic and now two countries vital to
sri lanka's tourism market are at war
russia and ukraine had been the first
and third largest source of visitors
this year
a failed drive to become the world's
first 100 organic farming nation hurt
food security sri lanka was forced to
import rice the tea crop the nation's
top export was devastated sri lanka now
wants china a major lender to
restructure its debt and it's
negotiating a one billion dollar relief
package from china's geopolitical rival
india
let's talk all of this through now with
dashal damel in colombo he's an
economist and research director at
verite research he served as economic
advisor to sri lanka's finance ministry
from 2017 to 2019. dashaw great to have
you with us um
is sri lanka on the verge of defaulting
on its debt
um so sri lanka is facing a very
challenged situation on its uh foreign
exchange
reserve position right now so it's
usable reserves that's excluding um a
1.5 billion dollar chinese yuan swap
amounted to just 734 million dollars at
the end of february that's enough that's
import coverage of around two and a half
weeks
um now in the months of february and
march sri lanka had liabilities maturing
amounting to 1.8 billion dollars so the
the the gap between usable reserves and
maturing liabilities is is clearly very
very high and not in sri lanka's favor
now there was a
deferment of 900 million dollars of an
acu payment asian clearing union payment
that was due to be paid earlier this
week that has been deferred by two
months so that does provide a little bit
of
leeway for the next few weeks but
overall sri lanka faces a very
challenging challenging situation on its
external uh external debt and its
foreign exchange reserves and the
government says that it can manage this
this situation on its own without
resorting to help from the imf is that a
wise strategy do you think so i would
think for sri lanka the most prudent
option now is to enter into negotiations
with with its creditors uh with a view
to restructuring its external debt to
restructure that uh you know in a
preemptive manner uh and such a
restructuring program would ideally be
underpinned and supported by an imf
agreement uh an imf agreement in that
situation would be able to unlock uh
some options of bridge bridge financing
that will help sri lanka to build up
reserves in the interim whilst it goes
through a debt restructuring process now
even if somehow sri lanka is able to
meet its maturing debt liabilities by
scraping together some swaps or
government transactions it's still doing
so at the expense of critical uh imports
for the economy imposed such as full
cooking gas and a number of other uh
imported commodities
as a result of which citizens are facing
a degree of hardship so really the best
balance from sri lanka's economic
perspective in the in the long term
would be to preemptively restructure its
external debt liabilities this an issue
that we've discussed many many times on
counting the cost how much of this
current crisis is due to the fact that
sri lanka is so indebted to china
so i would say that um
the current situation is not entirely
because of sri lanka's liabilities to
china so if you look at the upcoming
maturities over the next few years
typically around 20
of the maturing liabilities are
liabilities that are owed to uh or to
china uh the bulk of the
the bulk of liabilities actually arise
out of sri lanka's
borrowings from commercial markets or
from financial markets particularly
international sovereign bonds syndicated
loans and so on so whilst there is a
component of chinese
debt and chinese liabilities in this
in this equation i would not say that it
is the predominant cause of the
challenges sri lanka is facing right now
all right what so what is the cause we
talked a few moments ago about the now
scrapped policy to switch to 100 organic
farming
that
affected
exports and food security we talked
about the tea industry the biggest
export earner suffering is is there one
single cause or is just sri lanka in the
wrong place at the wrong time
economically at the moment so the the
the scrapping of um of chemical
fertilizer replacing with organic
fertilizer
that
we don't have evidence uh as yet to uh
to be able to attribute it to say the
decline in uh in t exports in in january
um survey data conducted by vedic
research does suggest that farmers do
expect significant uh decline in yield
so there would be uh some impact from uh
from that uh uh policy as well but sri
lanka's real problem is the fact that it
lost access to global credit markets
around early 2020 just before the the
the pandemic uh the pandemic hit by
losing access to global credit markets
it's been not been able to raise uh uh
uh capital to be able to refinance its
maturing debt so it has had to pay to
pay back debt using its reserves and
today reserves have as a result dwindled
down to the levels that we are at and
that's really the the crux of the
problem that sri lanka faces in foreign
exchange with sri lanka's tourism
industry taking such a big hit first of
all from the pandemic and now due to the
war in ukraine is there anything that
the government can do to to increase its
its
its foreign currency reserves you know
to earn
currency that it desperately needs
yeah so certainly the the point that
ukraine does have an impact on on sri
lanka's tourism which was just
recovering in the last few months um
around 25 percent of um
arrivals in the last few months have
been from uh either ukraine or russia uh
so the the the conflict that certainly
does have an impact on uh on the overall
balance of payments as does of course
the knock-on impacts that we're seeing
in global commodity prices particularly
uh particularly oil gas uh wheat and a
number of other uh important food
products as well because sri lanka is
the net importer so certainly the
current uh geopolitical challenges do
not work in sri lanka's favor in terms
of its uh in terms of its current
account that said the government has
taken some important positive steps in
in recent days it floated the rupee the
central bank floated the sri lankan
rupee a couple of days ago
and that certainly is a step in the
right direction towards encouraging more
inflows through formal uh banking
channels that can help the buildup of
reserve so that's certainly a positive
the central bank also recently uh raised
policy interest rates by 100 basis
points um at last week's monterey board
meeting again a positive in terms of
demand management and uh towards
building up reserves so there are steps
in the right direction there's still a
long way to go in terms of further
fiscal tightening further further moves
on the monetary side as well if that is
underpinned by an imf program and debt
restructuring i would think that is
really the way forward for sri lanka to
really sustainably build up its reserves
and to be able to both meet its external
debt repayments and provide the imports
that are required to sustain the economy
darshal it's been really good to talk to
you on county the cost many thanks
indeed for being with us
thank you very much
and that's our show for this week don't
forget you can get in touch with us if
you want to comment on anything that
you've seen you can tweet me i'm at a
finnegan on twitter please use the
hashtag ajctc when you do or you can
drop us a line counting the cost at al
jazeera.net is our email address there
is as always plenty more for you online
at aljazeera.com
ctc that takes you straight to our page
and there you'll find individual reports
links even entire episodes for you to
catch up on
but that is it for this edition of
counting the cost i'm adrian finnegan
from the whole team here in doha thanks
for being with us the news on al jazeera
is next